we
need to come together europe and the
united states could help
by harmonizing some of the regulations
and also the finance regulations
i know many companies are beginning to
become much more tuned in to their
stakeholder rather than just shareholder
responsibilities and i think there's
going to be increasing
focus on disclosure by
uh in by by companies with respect to
their preparation
for the impacts of climate and the way
in which that relates to the investing
world
and this disclosure is going to become i
think a very critical
driver of good investment moving into
alternative renewables sustainable
energy
different new kinds of energy whether
it's hydrogen different initiatives like
battery storage
or fusion or fission i mean there's so
many different possibilities
what europe and the united states could
do together i think
is help focus much of that energy many
of those
efforts and help to create a harmonizing
of the definitions and the rules and
regulations that will help govern
the allocation of capital growth
good afternoon uh looking forward to our
trip to kalamazoo
facility president biden will see where
much of the nation's
19 vaccines
the president is working closely with
manufacturers like bidner to get more
vaccine supply after american people
specifically the president used the
defense production act
to allow pfizer to receive priority for
orders of lipids
bags and filters to manufacture the
vaccine
he engaged the administration engaged
with pfizer suppliers to obtain the
equipment needed to expand manufacturing
capacity
including at the facility in kalamazoo
as you know
pfizer is on track to provide the u.s
120 million doses
by the end of march and 200 million
doses by the end of may
two months ahead of schedule will also
deliver an additional hundred million
dollars
helping up on track to have enough use
by the end of july hold on i have a few
more tiny things for you all
on the week ahead next week's
president will continue to bring the
american people together
to acknowledge the loss of suffered
during this pandemic
contain the virus on tuesday he will
engage in a discussion on black history
month
on wednesday he will receive a briefing
from his program 19 response team
on thursday he will deliver it virtually
to the national governors
association winter meeting and on friday
you will receive an economic briefing
with the treasury secretary
as always and we'll provide additional
details on his schedule
why do you think
he reiterated that the federal
government will continue to work
hand-in-hand with state and local
authorities
in texas bring the elite and address the
critical needs of the family's
effectiveness
as you heard him convey this morning we
will have a call with the acting fema
administrators
later this afternoon which we will
provide you all a readout of
he has his team expedite the request
made by the drama made by the
leader in texas uh the process how it
works is that
they face their number trusted fema fema
does an assessment
it then goes to our team in the white
house either dr
bliss or with randall he's actually
asked for that to be elected
and we will look to approve that and get
them the release of resources as quickly
as possible
uh we expect that this initial focus
will be on uh the counties that are most
impacted and prioritized by fema
but we will see as it goes through uh
why is now the time to engage with iran
um if there's a president plan to raise
issues along
the lines of iran's alliance
which is preventing iran from acquiring
a nuclear weapon
what was announced yesterday and what
the president reiterated today
is an openness to having a diplomatic
conversation
the europeans who are hosts of that have
offered to oppose that and we have
accepted
okay good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
i'm going to turn this over to
and yeah secretary in just a minute
he'll have a few opening comments
um and then we'll get to your questions
as you know
uh we're gonna be doing questions from
the phone and
in the room so i'm gonna go two on the
phone two in the room
secretary's got 30 minutes so we're
gonna try to move this crisply
given the restriction of time and his
schedule i'd ask you to limit your
follow-ups if you can
meaning limit them to zero uh so with
that mr secretary
over to you well good afternoon everyone
and thanks to all of you for being here
today
uh before i start uh let me just say
that i deeply appreciate the work that
you do on behalf of
the public executive order promising
like the way that you cover our military
in holding us accountable consider that
we decide
the europeans have invited us
nato defense
and ministerial was a terrific couple of
days and i want to thank uh
secretary general stoltenberg to
participate for all his leadership in
making that happen
between washington and you all know that
it's a little
[Music]
and many that we're
war in afghanistan what you mean about
when there'd be a persistent threat of
terrorism
oh yeah when it would be occurring in an
increasingly aggressive china
so we can move forward did he set up
some sort of interest
we were joined in some of those
conversations by representatives from
some of our most capable
partners including finland sweden and
the european union
especially about china
nato's work uh china and i made it clear
that the united states is committed to
defending the international rules
and part of the which china has
consistently undermined for its own
interests
jcpoa was that we here at the pentagon
and the department of defense view china
as our primary pacing challenge and we
believe nato can help us
better think through our operating
concepts and investment strategies
when it comes to meeting that challenge
but really my first goal this morning um
the ministerials was to carry forward
president
biden's message
and that foreign policy will be led by
our diplomats
a very notable democracy in the united
states i also stressed our iron
and contributions our shared
responsibility as allies
uh by making their community safer is to
protect our populations
and our territory and to meet that duty
we require what the secretary general
refers to
as distributed credible deterrence and
defense
and then also there is which i believe
means
each of us
and we want to see every member of the
alliance
contribute their fair share but
we recognize that this is this isn't
always easy working through
that organizing what security really is
you know there are a range of options on
the table for how the united neither are
the missions that we're conducting in
iraq or afghanistan
you set aside a good bit of time to talk
about those two places americans need to
be back
on iraq i reiterated our strong
commitment to the defeat of isis
and the iraqi minister of interior just
the other day
nato mission in iraq that responds to
the desires and aspirations of the iraqi
government
about china considering with respect to
afghanistan
i walked our allies through our thinking
as the new administration
comes to grips with the reality on the
ground
bottom line is this we are committed to
a responsible
and sustainable end to this war so i
will venture to do that
while preventing afghanistan from
becoming a safe haven for terrorists
earlier today and that threatened the
interests of the united states
including all relevant options with full
consideration
of the consequences of any potential
course of action with china
over like you're mindful of the looming
deadlines
i'm just not going to get ahead of our
we want to do this methodically and
deliberately
and so i urge all parties to choose the
path towards peace
the united states will not undertake a
hasty or disorderly withdrawal from
afghanistan
commanders have the right and a
responsibility to
defend themselves and their afghan
partners against attack
that he believes as we move forward in
our review
we will consult with our nato allies our
resolute support partners and of course
the government of afghanistan likely it
will survive and there will be no
surprises
we'll consult each other in a
parliamentary process
and consult together that process has to
decide together
he obviously
nato has proven itself to be the
strongest alliance in history
upholding our shared values of democracy
individual liberty
and the rule of law the easiest way an
article
was first invoked it was in our defense
on september 11th
nor will we forget our own obligations
to
revitalizing this and all our other
alliances
uh what what happened collective
security
i'd like to close by thanking the men
and women of the department of defense
who as president biden puts it are often
now
[Music]
thank you and i look forward
is
i would just say that again you know
we're going through a
rigorous process and our allies
understand that
uh and they would want us to make sure
that we're thoughtful about how we
approach this what we do sanders and his
team and
senators and members no all of us are
mindful of the time that
uh that's available but we're really
focused on making sure
that uh that negotiation process takes
place
as it should and that we are looking at
hopefully
the parties will abide by their their
commitments
uh that they made at the outset of the
negotiations and that violence will
you can bring the level of violence down
but we're focused on
making sure that we make the right
decisions and we'll go through this
process
deliberately our allies understand that
and my sense is that they did not fully
expect that we would
have a have a decision uh this early on
in our in this administration's team
next question to uh
um
uh
fedex and others so missy there was
quite a bit of feedback in the
transmission
i don't think i i fully understood all
of the questions
what i think i heard you asked was uh
based upon what we received from our
from the uh from the services
where are we in our efforts uh taking on
this number of
shippers and the second issue as i
understood it was
uh
i take this issue of sexual assault very
very seriously and i know that the
service chiefs and the service
secretaries do as well
and so the collection of the data is a
first step
but you can look for us to take
additional steps
in looking in detail at ourselves and
in what's worked what hasn't worked and
what measures we need to take going
forward
to ensure that we provide for a safe and
secure
productive environment for our teammates
i think any other approaches
in my view irresponsible we've been
working at this for a long time
in earnest but we haven't gotten it
right and my commit commitment to our
soldiers sailors airmen and marines and
dependencies
chat
some data and also it's now prohibited
under dod regulations to be an
active member of an extremist group but
okay to have simple
membership will you move to change
let me just say a couple of words about
that first of all
i think this is a very important issue
to us uh in the department
i think it's an important issue because
uh as i said in my testimonials
as you know there's ongoing people i've
asked for the services
right now there's an with ongoing troops
about
our values any other updates about the
oaths that they
they took when they came into the
service
and about who we are and what we're
about that's getting way ahead of where
we are in any process
this is also a time for us to educate
leaders
in terms of understanding
those signs and those symptoms that can
indicate that we could be developing
and they're doing the right thing
of course keeping the option open as you
all know quite frankly
they'll probably probably be a little
bit larger than most of us
with the 82nd airborne division which i
believe uh
was is a great uh organization and we
have a lot of great organizations in the
military but you noticed
the history of the story airport that's
where our focus is
and as we wrestled with this uh with
this issue when i was a lieutenant
colonel
what was the movie though we couldn't
tell the story of what we were doing and
how crazy it was because nobody wanted
anybody to hear about the skinheads
this image of mark milley lieutenant
general mark
one of our members who had become
that nearly crippled the the
organization for a period of time
so an incredible i think outside the
empire
and the american public should know and
understand that we're not afraid to take
a look at ourselves
and we're not afraid to uh to address
our issues to address those issues
uh that may be uh
rising up in our in our climates in our
communities
so we're going to learn a lot more you
know we don't have specific data about
about numbers right now but but quite
frankly as i said earlier
you know small numbers can have an
incredible impact on a great force and
we have a great force
ladies and gentlemen jennifer mr
secretary
will any u.s troops uh remain at the
capitol after march 12th
and what would you say to those who say
that there is no incredible
threat to the us capital and those
troops should go home right now
right now in terms of uh you know our
our expected uh stay
[Laughter]
it is you know march 12th uh
in and we don't have an additional
requirement or request from another
federal agency to provide them support
so that's our focus right now but while
i'm talking about them let me just
emphasize
the tremendous work that our guardsmen
have been doing
uh and you've been you've you know
you've seen the weather that we've had
lately
uh they are out there on point on guard
in support of other federal agencies
uh protecting our lawmakers and i can't
say
enough about them and i'm really proud
of what their what their leadership
is doing also to take care of them
while they're doing this tough work uh
but
uh presently we don't have any
additional requirements
beyond the one that that we just we
talked about incredible threat
you know i mean it's probably not
appropriate for me to talk about
intelligence matters from from this
podium but i
i would just tell you that we will
continue to assess
uh the threats as uh as we go forward
uh and decisions will be based upon you
know what we
believe is credible or not um
i told them when i when i went to see
them the other day that
you know my plan is to not keep them
what they're one day longer than it's
necessary
having said that uh they know and
understand that if our lawmakers need uh
need help they need they need protection
they stand ready to provide that
protection
but uh again march 12th is what we're
focused on now
okay i'm going to go to the phones phil
stork reuters
yes i'm mr secretary on your call with
your saudi counterpart
what message did you deliver about the
war in yemen
and how this administration and this
pentagon
will approach threats to the kingdom of
saudi arabia
emanating from yemen
well you know i uh i certainly
i i consider that call to have been a
good call
uh it was uh certainly reestablishing
connectivity with uh with the crown
prince
who is also the minister of defense my
counterpart
um as you know
president biden has been clear about the
fact that we will no longer support
uh offensive operations the saudis
offensive operations
into yemen and so they've heard that
message uh
loud and clear and in terms of specific
uh issues that i i would have covered
with uh with the crown prince you know
we provide a readout
but and i'm certainly uh you know i
i look forward to having some uh issues
or talking about
issues of substance uh in these
conversations
uh but i i certainly won't i won't
provide
details of the conversation from the
podium here
okay because of time i'm going to go
back into the room now we'll go one for
one until we
run out of time helene uh mr secretary
thank you for doing this
um i have two questions but they're
connected uh the first one
is you said that you found the viral
video they're both
related to females in the military you
found the viral video very
disturbing but in this video
this female marine says and i quote this
is why
females in the military kill themselves
and you say that you're looking into
this
issue she adjusted specifically the
commanding general
her cg's saying that um uh or whoever
the perpetrator is is going to be
retained in the military how
what kind of message are you going to be
sending to sort of the the
the cgs the captains the brigade
commanders throughout the military about
how they deal with this issue and
connected to that
my second question is on specifically
the issue of laura richardson
and jacqueline van os your predecessor
told
us that he withheld their promotions
because he was afraid
of how president trump would react to
them
are you going to be forwarding these
promotions for these two
women to president biden
helene i think that was two questions
each with six parts
yeah um on the on the second
question first um i
i certainly can't comment on decisions
that
someone else made or my my predecessor
made
i'll leave that to them to to explain
their actions
um and i certainly
won't won't comment on personnel actions
uh
from this podium in this room i don't
think that's fair to the system
not fair to my boss uh and certainly not
fair to the people
who are in the in who are competing i
would just say that i've seen the
records of
both of these women they are outstanding
and and so and i'll leave it at that um
on uh on the issue of sexual assault
and you know what's what is going to be
done and
and what i'm what what i'm going to
emphasize to uh to commanders
i think we need to consider who i am and
where i
fit in uh the judicial process
uh or our chain
and we want to make sure that you know i
preserve
my ability uh to
to adjudicate or take action or whatever
needs to happen
but the first things first things first
we have to get the facts we have to
understand what what just happened
uh and let me also say that uh
that you know i care about each and
every one of our of our troops
and certainly you know i'm gonna ask
that uh that er chain of command
make sure that someone is looking out
after her needs
and make sure that that we're taking
care of her so
okay uh back uh back to the phone here
uh
tara kopp from mcclatchy
thank you mr secretary for doing this i
also have a question about the national
guard
a few weeks ago the adjustments general
for the state of washington and
california
says that the domestic demands on the
guard
whether they're wildfires or storms or
domestic unrest are expected to continue
to in future years and what really needs
to happen is we need to increase the end
strength
of the guard i was wondering if you've
talked to the national guard about this
and if you're considering requesting an
end strength increase for guard members
to address these future domestic threats
thank you
uh again i'm i'm really proud
of our of the work that our guard has
done i mean it's it's and continues to
do
and we didn't talk about this earlier
but i think most of you know that there
are over 20 000 guardsmen out there
right now
around the country uh helping out with
uh with the covet crisis and
in helping distribute vaccines and that
sort of stuff
so they are doing they're having a
tremendous
positive effect on our country and
they're doing great work and i'm really
proud of them um in terms of
in strength that's a conversation that
i've not had with
with the chairman or the chief of the
guard
and certainly i think when they feel
that it's appropriate if that's
their concern then they'll bring it
bring the issue
uh forward but to answer your question
we've not had those discussions
the uh last last question today is gonna
go to tony then we're gonna have to wrap
up a china question
sorry the china question do you see any
areas of cooperation with china
you talk about a pacing threat casey
challenge this is four years we've heard
the rhetoric
what areas do you see potential
cooperation to lower the intentions
between
our two nations
i would say that that you know anything
that we do
will be based upon our best interest
and and so
there no doubt are some areas where
we we will see common interest and there
may be an
opportunity to to engage
but it will be from the standpoint of
promoting
our best interests now having said that
from a department of defense standpoint
as i mentioned earlier
you know my number one concern and my
number one
job is to defend this country and
protect
our interests and so we are in this
department are going to do everything
possible to ensure that we have the
right operational
concepts the right plans in place
and that we resource those plans with
the right capabilities
to present a credible deterrence
to not only to china or any other
adversary
uh who would want to want to take us off
thank you thanks everybody we have to
call it quits right there
thank you so much thank you very much
are you ready thank you everybody
thanks everybody thank you